[Musique]
recevoir les enfants au fort notre
nounours et bien élégant ce soir howie
patron je suis très chic
demain je vais faire des courses dont
les magasins chics de la rue de la paix
pour envoyer un paquet à ma soeur emilia
pour son anniversaire de mariage
c'est gentil ça nounours j'ai le sens de
la famille patron europe
mon échelle robe pourpre ou quittez pas
laver les dents nicolas mais si tu
apprenais bon alors moi je tenais j'ai
bien sale car un mouchoir ou soir vous
avez enfin le voilà nommé côté vous vous
trouvez quand tu pars pas en voyage au
moins non le dois simplement aller faire
quelques achats pour envoyer un cadeau à
ma chère soeur et 1000 da
qu'est ce que tu as là dedans c'est mon
porte-monnaie
ma petite tirelire à moi
andy dont elle est grosse non je le goût
monte
vous ne toucherez pas bien sûr nounours
[Musique]
et
voilà toute ma fortune sera c'est très
précieux
mais c'est une étoile de mer elle est
très rare elle me vient de ma tante
dhabi c'est un souvenir de fin 2010 dont
10 yens celle là nicolas nicolas
nous les enfants ce sont des bises ras
de billes on à gages du bébé a dit non à
celle là elle tire bien elles sont très
bonnes mais elles sont en or et en
argent
la maison blanche
monfort team baffour prime celle là elle
est où
moi qui voulait acheter un manteau de
fourrure match et faire c'était très
bonne nuit chronos gagner gros métal et
des mains ça non j'avais été trop aucun
petit chenapan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
du chaud lapin j'avais apportons breton
petit chenapan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
houle n'a que de bruit qu'est ce qu'il
se passe au pas ton patron un pope pour
corriger ce coq allons calme-toi
nounours et le moment j'ai toutes mes
économies patron uwe me pique mes
pauvres pigeons n'es tu ne peux pas
conduire notre nuage situé aussi un jt
ça va mieux pas trop je suis plus calme
alors haute nounours bonne nuit les
enfants fait beau rêve
[Musique]